AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKING HISTORY
THE FIRST AMERICAN PRESIDENT TO
EVER STEP FOOT ON NORTH KOREA
SOIL FOR A MEETING WITH KIM
JONG-UN TO RESTART THE NUCLEAR
NEGOTIATIONS AND THE EFFORT TO
GET THE REGIME TO DISMANTLE
THEIR WEAPONS.
HERE'S THE PRESIDENT TOUTING THE
PROGRESS.
>> WE DEVELOPED A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP.
IF YOU GO BACK 2.5 YEARS PRIOR
TO MY BECOMING PRESIDENT, IT WAS
A VERY, VERY BAD SITUATION.
A VERY DANGEROUS SITUATION FOR
SOUTH KOREA AND NORTH AND THE
WORLD.
IT WAS AN HONOR THAT YOU ASKED
ME TO STEP OVER THE LINE.
I WAS PROUD TO STEP OVER THE
LINE.
I TOLD YOU I MIGHT DO THAT.
>> THE VISIT MET WITH FEARS
CRITICISM.
>> DESPITE 3 YEARS OF ALMOST
BIZARRE FOREIGN POLICY FROM THIS
PRESIDENT, THIS COUNTRY IS NO
SAFER WHEN IT COMES TO NORTH
KOREA.
THEY LAUNCHED OTHER MISSILES
FLOUTING THE DIPLOMACY THIS
PRESIDENT HAS ATTEMPTED SO FAR.
WE ADDED LEJETIMACY TO KIM
JONG-UN.
>> IT'S WORY SOME THAT THE
PRESIDENT -- SETS UP A MEETING
WITHOUT THE STAFF WORKING BEING
DONE.
IT'S ALL FOR SHOW.
>> I AM ALL FOR SPEAKING WITH
OUR ADVERSARIES.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE THIS
PRESIDENT HAS RAISED THE PROFILE
OF A DICTATOR LIKE KIM JONG-UN
AND NOW 3 TIMES VISITED WITH HIM
UNSUCCESSFULLY.
BECAUSE HE IS DOING IT
BACKWARDS.
>> THIS IS HISTORIC.
HIM GOING TO NORTH KOREA IS LIKE
CHAMBERLAIN GOING TO TALK TO
HITLER.
>> EVERYBODY HAS TO JUMP ON THE
BANDWAGON.
A HISTORIC MOMENT.
THE TALKS WERE STALLED.
THE PRESIDENT WALKED AWAY FROM
THE LAST ONE.
THE STAFFS WERE NOT EVEN TALKING
TO EACH OTHER AND NOW THEY CAN
TALK AGAIN.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS THE PEACE
MARK ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
THAT'S WHAT THE SOUTH KOREA
PRESIDENT MOON SAID.
A LEFT OF CENTER LEADER.
PEOPLE IN THE REGION APPRECIATE
WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS DOING OVER
THERE DIPLOMATICALLY.
IT'S A PROCESS.
YOU CAN ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S HEADED
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
NO MORE NUCLEAR TESTING AND OUR
POSTURE IS STRONG IN THE REGION.
WE OPENED UP THE LARGEST U.S.
MILITARY PACE IN SOUTH KOREA.
THE NAVAL FLEET IS RIGHT OFF THE
COAST.
THEY ARE UNDER THE NUCLEAR
UMBRELLA.
EVERYTHING THAT OTHER PRESIDENTS
HAVE DONE HAVE NOT WORKED.
IT GOT MORE DANGEROUS IN NORTH
KOREA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIES SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
CRITICIZED THE ENTIRE TIME.
THE TWEETING AND THE SUMMITS.
WE ARE HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THERE IS A THAW AND HISTORIANS
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THIS WAS VERY
POWERFUL.
>> A SYMBOLIC MOMENT.
THE OTHER THING THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ABLE TO DO HE GOT
EVERYONE TO STOP TALKING ABOUT
THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATES.
>> YES.
OF COURSE THEY ARE GOING TO
ATTACK HIM.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WOULD DO.
IF IT WAS SOMEONE ON THE OTHER
SIDE, WE WOULD DO THE SAME
THING.
>> HOW DARE OBAMA MEET WITH HIM?
>> EXACTLY.
I WANT TO ATTACK A COUPLE OF THE
CRITICISMS.
IF YOU SEE DIPLOMACY AS A
WEAKNESS, WHAT DOES THAT LEAVE
YOU WITH?
THERE ARE ROUGH CUSTOMERS IN THE
WORLD AND YOU HAVE TO TALK TO
THEM.
YOUR GOAL IS TO REMOVE THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL THREATS PERCEIVED
BY THE ADVERSARY THAT THINKS YOU
WANT TO KILL THEM.
TRUMP SAID WE ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN BLOWING YOU UP.
YOU DON'T NEED THESE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
DID WE LOSE MONEY, LAND, OR
LIVES?
NO.
WE LOST OUR STATUS IN THE WORLD
WHILE WE ELEVATED HIS STATUS.
IF THAT'S HOW YOU VALUE THESE
THINGS YOU WILL NEVER MAKE
PROGRESS.
IF YOU SAY DIPLOMACY CAUSES A
LOSS OF STATUS, WHY HAVE
DIPLOMACY AT ALL?
WE ARE IN A BETTER SITUATION
THAN 2 YEARS AGO.
WE REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
HAWAII THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOOD-BYE TOING NUKED.
I -- THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
BE NUKED.
I PREFER THIS TO THAT.
>> AND THEY DO TOO.
>> JUAN, DO YOU WANT TO PLAY
JESSE'S FAVORITE GAME WHAT
ABOUT?
>> OBAMA WAS TALKING ABOUT LET'S
TALK TO CUBA.
THIS  IS TERRIBLE.
>> YOU COULD NOT TRUST OBAMA.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WHOEVER YOU SUPPORT, YOU
TRUST THAT PERSON.
>> THE BIG ISSUE FOR ME IS
TRUMP'S GESTURE A PHOTO-OP IS
NOT STOPPING THEM FROM GETTING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THEY ARE ACCEPTING THEM AS A
NUCLEAR POWER.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS
REPORTING THIS.
>> THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN WRONG.
>> JOHN BOLTON SAID WE DIDN'T
TALK ABOUT THIS IN NATIONAL
SECURITY.
ONE LAST POINT.
FOR ALL OF US AT THIS TABLE, I
THINK WE WERE ALL SENSITIVE TO
OTTO WARMBIER AND WHAT HIS
FAMILY WENT THROUGH AND THE IDEA
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP GOES OVER
THERE IS PALLING AROUND AND
SAYING NICE THINGS ABOUT KIM
JONG-UN WHO TORTURED AND I THINK
KILLED AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
THAT'S DISRESPECTFUL TO HIM AND
HIS FAMILY.
>> BECAUSE OF OTTO WARMBIER, WE
WENT DOWN HARD ON WHAT THEY DID.
SO WE SHOULD NOT HAVE ANY
DIPLOMACY?
DO YOU THINK HIS FAMILY IS OKAY
WITH THAT?
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES GIVING HIS --
>> JUAN, PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD
GO BACK TO FIRE AND FURY
TOMORROW.
HE IS UNPREDICTABLE.
HE IS TRYING TO CONVINCE KIM
JONG-UN DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
ISOLATED TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND NUCLEAR WEAPONS ARE
NOT KEY TO THE REGIME'S
SURVIVAL.
THE ARGUMENT HE IS TRYING TO
MAKE, IF YOU WATCH THE VIDEO
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESENTED.
KIM JONG-UN IN SINGAPORE, IT'S
AN INTERESTING VIDEO.
IT SHOWS THE DIVERGING PATHS
THAT NORTH KOREA COULD GO ON.
ONE IS ISOLATION AND
DESTRUCTION.
THE OTHER IS PROSPERITY AND
PEACE.
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CONTINUING TO
MAKE TO NORTH KOREA.
THESE ARE 2 THE PATHS YOU HAVE
AND THE 2 CHOICES YOU HAVE.
ONE OR THE OTHER.
EVERYTHING WE HAVE SEEN OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TO INCREASE
DIPLOMACY TO PUSH HIM IN THE
CORNER OF PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
>> WE'RE NOT WAR WITH NORTH
KOREA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WE
DON'T LIKE.
BUT WE ARE STUCK ON THIS EARTH
TOGETHER.
MAYBE IT TAKES SOMEONE WITH A
PERSUASION SKILL SET TO BREAK
THIS OPEN.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S HAPPENING.
>> THEY HAD 3 MEETINGS.
>> IT MIGHT TAKE 6 YEARS.
>> I HAVE DON'T TRUST OBAMA
UNDSCORED?
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
[LAUGHING].
>> THE POINT IS, YOU CAN RESPECT
OBAMA AND THINK HE IS BETTER IN
SOME THINGS THAN TRUMP IS.
I DON'T THINK HE THE RIGHT MAN
FOR THIS JOB.
TRUMP HAD A DIFFERENT SKILL SET
TO DEAL WITH THIS GUY THAT I
DON'T THINK OBAMA HAD.
>> OBAMA WOULD HAVE GIVEN HIM
150-BILLION DOLLARS.
>> ON A SERIOUS NOTE, WHAT DOES
THIS IS A TO IRANS THAT IRAN
STARTS TO VIOLATE THE DEAL WE
ABANDONED?
YOU ARE LETTING NORTH KOREA HAVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO GET BETTER DEALS WITH
THE IRANIANS AND THE NORTH
KOREANS BECAUSE THE DEALS BEFORE